Straight. I can start again.
And i remember watching one of his kind of derelicts and and people at that in the street
and especially this one guy called trey who i'm sure you'll hear about time and time again. And.
He would sit in the straight and sort of try and beg from paypal
and just talked himself because he's actually quite insane and.
The money that he used to get from his doll checks and from. Begging from people.
He would line up in rows of sort of one and two saying coins were ten ten paces in the straight.
And he would count his why along them.
And and work out whether he was actually going to have enough to buy a flag in that day.
And he would kind of put a mark of further off in the strain i remember watching him do it quite clearly.
He put a marker a piece of wood where his coins would have to get to in order for him to be able to afford this flag
and i just thought well this really is a desperate situation isn't it. I mean i had.
You know two dollars fifty in my pocket myself to go and by law is within you know that wasn't a problem
but this guy just didn't have under control and there are a lot of people like that who are kind of sit
and have really slow kind of.
Maining with arguments in the street and they would never raise their voices or actually get animated
or anything like that just sit there and argue it out old dying get really in-depth vet everything.
And then are in the other people who just kind of sit there with a guitar with their bungalows
and not ply them with alice and say you know you
and so you'd walk past some really hairy find you seen they're looking at his guitar. And he hasn't worked out yet.
You know that he's not playing all that he can play it. You know to skate. You know just keep going. You know.
I remember the one. You know when people receive these tynan and sort of dance around.
And they're getting right into it and feeling really good about everything and kind of. You know.
Makes everyone feel a little bit uncomfortable. These people are doing it because it is something really.
Last about it. And you know. I mean i remember a lot of sort of messy situations where people would.
Would fight about money or. About something like that and then. And.
And i would say another person come in and set a little down and. Like say say people being treated like.
Children all the time. That's really funny thing because you know. It's like you know communities with.
Whenever things blow up there are always people a step in and try and sort them out. And so this i mean even when.
All of you know.
When the situation on the street got out of hand the paper would step in and diffuse little and sort of.
Pat if you're on the back and say you know it's like when you don't have to worry about it. And you know.
As often as not. These situations would just sort of die down straight away. And i mean.
And i would probably have an image of the place. As being very kind of nasty. And violent.
And i would have dark side twelve. That. But he does have to remember that it's people trying to get on with a thing.
And those situations can. You know it can actually be resolved as well and. So knowing. You know. All right.
The other thing is like even.
All of those families like ours that when it moved down there and lived in a half built tent
or something like that you know. We always had sort of food and beds and our own sort of domestic situation sorted out.
You know. And there was this whole other group of people that i haven't really talked about. Yet. The kind of.
Feral people who have chosen to live in a completely kind of feral existence. Up in in the bush is with now you can of.
You know civilized housing or any of that type of thing. And they get really really dirty.
And they live in a really really primitive way. And it's funny because i know that they're living in a primitive way.
And that they're not sort of. You know. Having any kind of western. You know.
Material things around them or anything like that. But then again.
They're doing it as a reaction to the western way of living and so what they're doing is kind of like.
Anti western living. As opposed to just a natural instinct to feral way of living which indigenous people would do and.
It's really funny to see the lengths that they have to go to in order to maintain a kind of really simple and and.
Unconscious type of lifestyle and you know. But the whole thing about. You know. Having a cough example.
One of the more i have a car because eventually they're going to have to go somewhere. And and. You know.
But i'd like to sort of pretend that i don't have a car and they don't need any of that type of stuff coming. And.
And so you've got these kind of groups of people making a massive effort to leave. You know really kind of simple way.
And going out of their way to do it continuously.
I mean my whole life i've never actually stopped to think why that would doing it because like there are some things
like pornography and you know. Advertising and things like that which i really dislike about our consumers to society.
But then. There you know. All of the rest of it seems quite acceptable to me. Whether you take it on.
As a really serious type of thing where you just do it without thinking about it.
And so i don't see what actually requires that if it. Was through.
Well you know this that you know there's also the dilemma that they are trying to be self-sufficient
but in the end they're going to need to get some money somehow. And so they can rely on. Society to support them.
Or they can try and produce something that's all value.
And when they you know when they produce those things like the things i sell the markets
and stuff like that they're trying to in the most organic. Kind of. Or you know down to earth possible way.
But they're still relying on a very kind of. You know western society approach to doing the whole thing.
In order to make it work. And so you know. Even though they validate alternative lifestyles. They should.
You know be careful to acknowledge that they're still kind of participating in our mainstream society
and that it's still sort of. You know tourists and.
Those kind of people who are buying their things and supporting their lifestyle. You know as.
Removed and as simple as i think that monday. You see these. Valuable those this guy who's.
There's this guy who was there before i arrived who.
Was convinced that eileen's when they were going to come down and sort of. You know the whole planet.
And that was going to happen on this particular night in this particular place. And he took a whole lot of pay.
Well there. And they stayed up all mine.
And watched a couple of satellites going overhead and were almost convinced at one stage
but neither no hole kind of fell down.
I mean it was one of those classic things where the actual event didn't tie place. But the purpose of the event.
You know i was just as powerful anyway because all these people were actually brought together by at. And you know.
And something started. Through and that was out of my own bimby and you know.
They ended up starting from medical communes out there. And you know he was a big part of all of that.
But just you know a lot of those kind of trippers who make everyone stop
and listen to their story about whether it's eileen's. Or about armageddon or whatever you know i have over.
This sort of thing in common where all i want is for everyone to gather around and listen to their story.
But the actual contents of the story are usually completely meaningless or you know. Completely. Nonsense.
And i'm putting forward to you my. My proposition that it's.
The police that are largely responsible for the i have a willing. Presence of.
The hard drug scene in nimbin at the moment. I mean.
I believe that it's just that there are too many of them i mean there's bound to be a small number of people using
narcotics in any culture. At the moment in australia and. Particularly in a culture where the other drugs.
Such an integral part of the community. But the policing is the problem at the moment i think the policing in.
The reason that the police want police name is a very simple one and that relates to their envy.
Envy is a very basic human feeling like anger and avarice and sloth and the other seven deadly sins.
Envy is ubiquitous. I personally feel that it was in v. That was the problem. On air con.
In that might it impossible for us to share.
I think it was not possible for some of the other people not to invade the why i could easily mike. Money.
And that this. Distorted in all sorts of complicated whys the things that was going down.
But i think the envy that the police. Feel for those of us that name is very very deep and very very profound.
For the first few years when i had this wonderful relationship with the one policeman in town.
I think that the situation was very very different.
But then he actually left the town because he couldn't cope with just how ambiguous
and complicated it was he was a lovely guy but he said himself.
I can't go on with this amount of ambiguity
and i doubt our my kids to be growing up in a drug plan like this i've got a god.
And from then on we had a succession of policeman and police women. In various numbers coming there. Who i think.
Really heighted name. My height and envy people like me. By height. And to some extent.
Envy people who are on the dolls. And who can grow and to run a car on the dial.
And live a pretty comfortable lifestyle.
Not a wonderful lifestyle but the lifestyle of the average policeman with a mortgage and.
All of those things is not all that bloody comfortable.
Saw the side of a bunch of people on the dollar still driving a car and. Never working.
The bunch of a the side of people like me who can cross the boundaries between. The professional.
Groupings and the tribe out there and live a comfortable lifestyle in my view even drive a sports car.
I think that the police a tremendously. Envious of. Most of the asp. Picts of the nieman phenomenon.
Therefore i will not do what i would do in any other place when it comes to crime.
I think i rather feel that we should steal an hour and sheet.
Firstly that i can always justify their inactivity with respect to the hard drugs by saying i am
but you just want us to bust the narcotics people. And ally off few dives micah's. And of course.
That's not what a policeman is supposed to do. All right. We lie off the dogs muggers. But don't you expect us then.
To be discriminating. That's not what a policeman is supposed to do.
So they have a rational irrational rationalize i shun for going easy on the more obvious narcotic.
Dealing and using the guys on in town. But that's just the rationale. What's behind it is to hype that place.
By height. The in height of the intelligentsia the height. The artists.
But that's not what a policeman is about policemen the not about the finer things in life policeman.
By choice actually come into contact with some of the most disastrous human beings in the community
and i've got a valve job. And i'm not sighing that their envy is unique.
I've just said that envy i think fucked up my community. But i think that in this particular case.
It is the envy of the police. That forces them into a particular level of activity.
Which then ensures that we have a very special drug problem in name.
And i will not police that town and i will not walk around that town. The police department.
Will not put on and off police for them to just walk around the town. There's a certain sort of. Overt drug use.
Which just couldn't happen. If there was a policeman walking. By bluefin doesn't have to even do anything.
He just has to be there. Or she has to be there. So i want to do that in him and i just want.
And i say well that's because we'd have to book the docks marcus but that's not the cause.
Well firstly i wouldn't have to. And i could actually be discriminating.
Policeman of discriminating all the time but i'd bust each other for speeding. So we're up against a team name.
With the fact that the police are not giving us a fair deal about. Hard drug users. Just not policing it.
And that's because i want to ask to steal an hour and cheat.
Well i still don't think i can do it without the police cooperation.
Yes it is true that we've never been able to draw a line survive never been able to draw lines in name one
and the have all wise. Been in difficulty and finally deciding that x. Is gone too far. Unless it's. That x.
Is gone too far in asserting some sort of leadership. If if x.
Begins to assert something that might be interpreted as ladyship i've got the shit kicked out of the matey of late
but if you go too far with respect to shooting in the middle of the mind straight
or anything like that it would be very hard for naman to draw the line. So yes. Obviously enough.
There's a potential for for serious. Illegal drug users to two pariah.
Themselves in name been without getting the usual public condemnation. The. Might keep them in order.
But i don't think that we could do anything in name in a map that problem unless the police actually kind plain.
And the police applying it very dirty in the middle. Yeah now i'm not i'm not happy about.
The why that continues to be a feature of nieman law. And it is the. I mean it's a movie again.
Awful of the why in which leadership. Is dissolved dispersed. Denied.
In name and is another real example of just what a very very important part in human affairs envy plies.
Of course once again. There is a rationale for it in naman. You know.
If everybody's to be free and autonomous and way to have a real anarchy then.
Obviously enough now one should leave because i would have to impose their particular style on other people and.
That is you know. Then the false. Rationale for. Tearing down leaders. It's in the.
It's in the interests of anarchy and real autonomy.
That we have to get rid of the sort of people who want to be leaderless
but i've already said that i think that that's a disaster. And that's not ride.
But i also believe that the tearing down of leaders. Is. You know the prime.
The cardinal example of a strike is endemic. Of australians endemic envy.
Which is which runs very deep in a horse tryon's might have something to do with our convict background or something.
But i think it is. It's a bad thing it would be wonderful if we could i have a cow.
And we would want to have a comment until we acknowledge just how many areas of life.
Of our own personal lives and of our larger lives as a community. Until we acknowledge how deeply.
Envy provides our community. So poor our name and has not managed to transit and. The problem that you know.
I think bedevils all of a stride you. With respect to the toll poppy syndrome niman hasn't.
Transcended that and simply because you know name been. Has interpreted anneke and. And freedom as.
Maining they would not be and they would not need to be leaders.
And i of course believe that's complete nonsense i think that we have to have inspirational human beings around us.
In order to be inspired. And in order to write e ict light. Selves we need to be exposed to righty and. Beings.
There have been a lot of people at nieman who are pretty righty and sort of creatures and i do get a pretty rough time.
Yeah well. Yes. Yes. Matings have benefit share of. Naman.
And i have taken the sime form from die one where anybody who attempted to take a real leadership role has come.
Has come. Adrift. And where everybody. You know has the right to be heard. Good and.
There are some aspects of that which i really appreciate i. I think that are actually on my.
I'm not a member of the quietest but i am a quiet regular attender it. Quite amazing.
And you mind that quite as were the. The first group of people to enshrine consensus. As.
The most appropriate why of decision miking. Well i really do appreciate the fact that it name and there isn't a tame.
All wise. To to find some sort of consensus in mating. Now of course just as with the quite as i mean.
You're all nighters that you don't know many quite as they're not a very evangelical bunch and they're very quiet
and very live profile and.
Usually very beautiful people but it certainly isn't the movement that's taken over the world and.
That is undoubtedly a consequence of their commitment to this. Fascinating process of consensus.
And that's what everybody tries for all of the meetings in women.
And just as the quiet is only of a tiger over the world there's no doubt that what it is that's happening at niman
eleven dyck over the world because of their commitment to. Everybody being hood. And particularly everybody trying to.
You know to come from their higher self in their communications with other people.
But it does mane that you have to listen to some assholes and. That certainly you know. Bogs down the process.
My pleasure and privilege.